Law and Order Special Victims Unit star
Richard Belzer passed away early Sunday
morning the friend of Belzer is
confirmed to The Hollywood Reporter that
the actor was suffering from health
issues the veteran actor was 78 a
notable comedian Belzer eventually found
the role of a lifetime when he became
one of TV's most prolific cops John
Munch he first appeared as Munch in
NBC's homicide life on the street only
to return as a character and Law and
Order SVU here's a clue non-gun hand
held to the side
[Music]
Belzer was committed to the Law and
Order character for over 20 years
playing him across several shows though
sbu was the detective's main bread and
butter Belzer said in a 2017 chat with
smashing interviews magazine the writers
got to know me the character of munch
was really close to how I do things it
was a dream come true for me and an
utter Delight to play this character for
so many years but bells are so attached
to his sbu role it's no surprise that
several of the actors former colleagues
are reacting to his passing Belzer's SVU
co-star Christopher Maloney shared on
Twitter goodbye Mona me I love you the
bells attached to Maloney's heartfelt
message was a photo of the Elliot
Stabler actor kissing Belzer on the
cheek Maloney followed up his original
reaction by sharing a photo of Belzer
and Mariska hargate on the set of the
Law and Order series reminding fans just
how adorable the two were Mariska
Hargitay best known to fans as the
Unstoppable Olivia Benson in Special
Victims units took to Instagram to pay
tribute to her late co-star in an
emotional pose hargate described Richard
Belzer as a quote dear dear friend
architect wrote I will miss you your
unique light and your singular Take On
The Strange World I feel blessed to have
known you and adored you and worked with
you side by side for so many years how
lucky the angels are to have you I can
hear them laughing already I love you so
very much now and forever district
attorney Casey Novak actor Diane Neal
expressed her grief on Instagram sharing
several photos of Belzer and herself to
her followers Neil wrote Uncle Belzer my
hero we always had fun genuinely at work
on vacation anywhere the man who made
every moment better I will miss you
terribly oscar-winning actress Marley
Matlin who made a brief appearance in
SVU also shared her memories of Belzer
on Twitter Matlin tweeted Richard Belzer
was one of the most kind and welcoming
actors when I guessed it on two episodes
of Law and Order SVU his passing is
truly a loss for Hollywood and I will
miss him dearly rest in peace Richard
Belzer Those Behind the Law and Order
cameras also remembered the actor
following his passing former SVU
showrunner Warren light tweeted Richard
Belzer was the first actor to welcome me
when I started at SVU open warm acerbic
whip smart surprisingly kind I loved
writing for Munch and I loved being with
bells these kind sentiments were also
echoed by sbu writer Neil bear who
described the actor as a quote comic
genius and a heartfelt Twitter post Law
and Order franchise veteran and SVU
executive producer Julie Martin paid
tribute to the actor on Twitter shortly
after his death was confirmed Martin
shared missing Richard Belzer today
working with him on homicide the sbu has
been a hilarious surprising and always
joyful experience I'm sure he's given
them all a lot of laughs upstairs
[Music]